halt halt hier wird nicht gedopt ist ja
[Musik]
erst mal kurz die bauleute ich kann euch
beruhigen wenn auch ihr da draußen mal
wieder in der alltäglichen situation
seit dass ihr schülerseite und so ein
bisschen ein auge auf dem gewissen
lehrer geworfen hat und auch schon
schritte daraufhin macht mit diesem
lehrer was zu starten aber einfach immer
prinzipiell immer und jedes mal geblockt
werden es für euch jetzt der perfekte
ratgeber da wir haben sie schon in ferne
gesehen oder wir schauen sollte wieder
eine hilfe folge an und zwar eine hilfe
der folge nicht mehr gedacht habt zumal
sebastian das wollen die leute wirklich
wissen dass wollen sie sehen die leute
wollen wissen was mache ich wenn ich mir
ein lehrer klären will aber einfach
immer gestört werden ja da habe ich mir
genau dafür den passenden ratgeber
rausgesucht der heißt mein heißer
biolehrer aber jeder kommt uns
dazwischen jeder schülerin jeanette 18
referendar fabian 25 und schulleiter
paul 44 und willigen geht's los
juni bleibst du mal wieder kurz hier ich
habe echt keine lust mehr darauf dass du
ständig den unterricht stört okay hier
stellen wir schon mal unseren referendar
fabian 25 zu haben der aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach das objekt der
begierde von einer jungen schülerin ist
die schülerin wird uns hier beschreiben
haben sogar schon gesagt mit jeanette 18
vorgestellt die hat er jetzt juli
genannt also empfiehlt mir wieder
namentlich richtigen bekommen oder dass
eine andere person deine mitschüler ab
längst und mit einem handy noch spiel
und ich habe keine lust dazu sitzen von
mir gab anzuhören ich bin riesig die
einzige die ihren unterricht langweilig
hält ja solche schüler wünscht man sich
als lehrer als referendar natürlich noch
ein bisschen früher an der ausbildung
ist man lässt sich noch nicht ganz so
sicher
man ist selbst noch ja einfach und
sicher in diesem arbeitsumfeld genau das
ist der zeitpunkt wann möchte dass
schülerinnen am ende der stunde zu einem
nach vorne kommt und ihren dann sagen so
übrigens darunter richtig scheiße das
nächste mal wenn du dich noch mal so auf
willst dann musst du mit konsequenzen
rechnen
mir reicht's echt gut auf wiedersehen
okay die scheinbar keine kosten gescheut
und hat tatsächlich zwei schülerinnen in
dieser folge die eine wie gesagt juni um
ist jetzt gerade eben hier raus gestimmt
und jetzt verbleiben wollte jetzt wird
es spannend für alle von euch die sich
auch gerade ein lehrer oder eine
lehrerin klären wollen und ich wissen
wie jetzt wird's spannend jetzt
verbleiben jeanette und fabian in diesem
klassenraum und jetzt gesamt ok dazu
gibt es gleich ein paar punkte zu sagen
nummer eins sie bittet den lehrer über
die letzte bio prüfen zu reden so aber
er ist allem englisch lehrer sondern der
tafel stehen nämlich die sache auf
englisch aber okay geschenk vielleicht
ist er ja englisch und lehrer zweite
sache auf jeden fall starke reaktion von
ihm an der stelle schülerin kommt zu ihm
nach vorne
in meiner not machen wenn ich mich jetzt
hier ausziehen kann ich dann vielleicht
ein paar mehr punkte haben und er ist so
doch nicht hier also ich würde jederzeit
eine beziehung mit einer schülerin
anfang arbeite ich in der schule
das hat ja nicht wirklich lange gehalten
mit wir können doch nicht hier sein
die topleute das ist eine sache die ich
in meinem leben nicht verstehen werde
als lehrer
studiert man glaube ich mindestens vier
jahre und muss dann immer noch zwei
jahre referiert machen oder so also man
ist sechs jahre in der ausbildung okay
dafür dass man diesen job machen kann
und dann hat man endlich diesen job nach
jahren harter arbeit und dann kommt eine
schülerin angesagt so jo unter der ja
auch meinen job
halt hier wird nicht gedopt ist ja alles
in ordnung
[Musik]
ganz normale art und weise in den
klassenraum reinzukommen dass man bevor
man reinschauen kann schon beruft halt
hier wird nicht gedopt so du hast du gar
nicht gesehen was in diesem raum
vorgehen macht ihr immer so weil man
auch so stoppt schreibe dass man so
stoppt also aufhören bevor er überhaupt
was abgeht finke wie kann ich ihnen denn
weiterhin für fabian ist das eine heikle
situation
auch wenn gegenliebe kein kraut
gewachsen ist sollte er sich dieser
beziehung nicht einfach hin geben also
noch mal leute heikle situation ist
wirklich eine krasse untertreibung der
typ verliert unter garantie seinen job
wenn rauskommt dass er mit einer
schülerin aus hat save der job ist weg
sechs jahre studium für naschen warum
man nicht die finger von der 18-jährigen
lassen konnte möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen es kann ihn und auch
janet in große schwierigkeiten bringen
ich wollte einen termin heute nachmittag
erinnern ja ich weiß bescheid ich habe
ich nicht vergessen
jaja klassiker man kennt diese
schuldirektoren die zu um die fünfzig
sechzig sind die ja quasi am ende und in
der höchsten stufe ihrer karriere als
lehrer angekommen sind die viel zu tun
um die ganze schule organisieren wollen
die gehen natürlich immer in die
klassenzimmer und erinnern lehrer an
termine
die haben nichts besseres zu tun schon
einmal vor sagte schulleiter und die
macht nichts anderes als fucking
kalender app einfach leute dran erinnern
dass die termine haben trotzdem ist dann
ist da
fabian hatte richtig glück gehabt wenn
der direktor die beiden knutschen
erwischt hätte hätte er ihn sofort vom
dienst suspendieren kann fabian hat
richtig glück gehabt hätte der
schuldirektor ak google kalender app
nicht lautstark angekündigt dass er
reinkommt dann hätte ihn erwischt ja
gott sei dank sind wir hier bei hilf mir
und leute kündigen schreibt anders in
den raum rein kommen bevor sie sehen was
in dem raum passiert
ich habe ja bis zu völlig verrückt
geworden hast du vor die finger von mir
ist nicht klar dass wir gerade fast
erwischt worden sind ja er ist sehr
konsequent auf jeden fall
jetzt ist also also was fällt dir eigen
die kanzel nicht nur in ein eigentümer
meter radius um mich herum rein begeben
vor zehn sekunden auch so wir können
hier nicht reden es kann jederzeit
jemand kommen und ich setze ganz sicher
nicht meinen traumjob und mein gehalt
aufspielen doch dort genau das was du
gerade eben schon gemacht und wir können
nicht mit sicherheit sagen dass wir da
keiner gesehen hat weil also ich gehe
mal davon aus dass der klassenraum auf
fenster hat ne also hier ist die wand
mit der tür und auf der anderen seite
sind fenster fahrzeugen reingeschaut
leute jetzt endlich ersetzt dafür nicht
seinen job aufs spiel erstmal kurz
überlegen flammen entfernt von meiner
mutter und sie nur das konnte an und
einfarbig dann also ich will mich
eigentlich immer wird das lustig machen
was die leute sagen aber an der stelle
muss hier wirklich recht geben
zweifelsohne der typ kommt überhaupt
nicht klar egal er kann sich nicht mal
im klassenzimmer zurückhaltend was mit
der schülerin zu starten denn sie dann
vor seiner haustür auf doch dann dann
rappelt erst recht
das ist hier wirklich schon jetzt auch
leute gebt fabian gibt habe ich ein paar
sekunden die ganze sache wird sich sehr
bald ändern
was mir auch gerade aufhält das problem
in dieser hilfe erfolge ist ja nicht so
uneinig habe was mit meinem lehrer
gehabt so was soll ich machen sondern
das problem ist achter auf den titel
jeder kommt uns dazwischen also das
problem was man quasi jetzt hier mit
einer ratgeberserie lösen will ist wie
schaffe ich es mit meinem lehrer was zu
haben ohne dass mich leute stören also
quasi wirtschaftlich undercover
beziehung mit meinem lehrer zu haben
nicht unbedingt die klügste entscheidung
ich will das nicht
warst du verrückt ich bin gerne folge
lag was mit dem titel los gerade eben
noch so mehr auf gar keinen fall können
wir was haben fünf sekunden später sie
zeigt so ein quadratzentimeter haut also
das kannst du nicht machen
ich setze ganz sicher nicht mein
hauptjob und mein gehalt auch schon mal
sagen du hast ist wirklich einfach drauf
deine selbstkontrolle ist wirklich ein
ding da kann sich ganz deutschland ein
beispiel dran nehmen dass es tatsächlich
geschafft ganze drei sekunden
auszuhalten
ja genau so leute sieht es aus wenn man
nicht seine karriere und sein gehalt
aufs spiel setzt natürlich ist es schön
also ohne wird sollte es muss doch
wirklich da zwischen geräten bei diesen
experten so da ist immer noch so ein
unterton mit dabei von so ja ok ja ja
wird schon passen also es ist nicht so
gut aber es ist auch nicht so ganz
schlimm alter checkt ihr es noch der typ
setzt gerade sechs jahre seines lebens
aufs spiel stellt euch mal vor ihr
arbeitet sechs jahre auf ein ziel hin
und werd es dann einfach in den
mülleimer
weil ein 18-jähriger in lauerstellung
ganz klar die einzigste fertig liebe bis
tun
aber was ist wenn alles den bach
runtergeht du bist wirklich mehr zu
retten
wie war das nochmal mit ist soll ich
mich erinnere mich gerade so wieder von
ganz ganz langer zeit habe ich irgendwas
gehört von wegen sachen nicht aufs spiel
setzen ich setze ganz sicher nicht mal
einen traumjob und mein gehalt auch
spielen du bist einfach der king du hast
es wirklich geschafft du hast den
widrigkeiten des lebens getrotzt
du hast wirklich eine herausforderung
die stirn geboten und hass als 25
jähriger lehrer mit einer 18 jährigen
schülerin was an
du bist echt nicht mehr zu retten ich
muss mal ein paar von über 30.000 häuser
noch zurückzahlen muss miete zahlen
strom handy und als referendar für die
nicht auch nicht die welt ja okay und
was machen wir dann also nochmal wir
fassen noch mal zusammen du hast
schulden
du verdienst wird leute was macht man in
dieser situation wenn man schulden hat
und wenig verdient genau man setzt
seinen job wegen einer absoluten
hirnrissig kite ausspielen und ich habe
noch ein bisschen weiter es gibt für
euch und es ist wirklich unfassbar auf
mysteriöse art und weise hat fabian
tatsächlich sein leben verpackt er macht
später noch mit seiner schülerin rom
wird dabei von anderen schülerinnen
gefilmt und die erpressten damit hätte
hätte irgendjemand dass das kommen sie
wenn irgend einer von euch da draußen
eventuell lehrer oder lehrerin ist und
sich überlegt mit einem schüler oder
eine schülerin was zu starten dann
möchte ich euch an der stelle bitte
diesen ratschlag geben kommt auf euer
leben klar
dann macht es nicht frage an euch heute
gab es in eurer schule irgendwas tories
von lehrer die was mit schülern gehabt
haben oder habt ihr euch selbst
vielleicht mal an der verrückte und in
die kommentare ein check hier ein
kleines video ab hier oben könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren ich bin raus ich
große augen macht gut